we rolling
I'll be rolling are we rolling
I'll be rolling this is my life I'm are
Kelly and this is my life this is my
life isn't my how am i Kelly and this is
my lie grew up on the south side chicago
born in 1967 and my eyes have seen a lot
of things coming up in the hood Jeffrey
- I kill Gardens 63rd and Michigan all
the south side
what no punk man I tell you I've seen a
lot of junk you know coming up
you know I'm been through a lotta my mom
my family though we had not much of
anything
we had family we had us we had love and
I believe no I know that's what got us
through you know that's what landed me
here I fell from the sky landed on the
ground
all I know is man you know I was like a
sea I was like fish in the middle of an
ocean and then I woke up as a well in
the middle of a pond
that's how it went down for me man I
blink my eyes and next thing you know I
was in the midst of success in the midst
of drama in the midst of rumors in the
midst of love but in the midst of haters
but somehow my gift which was my music
my depth of struggle was fed into my
gift and somehow my gift ignited to the
point where I was able to communicate
with the world and that's the world to
rescue me and the men and I opened my
mouth and started to sing oh that
changed everything and I don't know
where nowhere I mean I walked through
the drug dealers walked through the
pimps and the holes and the hustlers
through the hood the drugs was offered
to me I've been shot up and stabbed but
I still to this day made a tree out of
the slums out of the alleys out of the
the deep deep deep dark hood sometimes I
don't know sometimes I don't know just
how I got here just how I made it just
how I made it just how I made it
but I'm glad I did I'm glad I did all I
want to do is music you know ever since
I was a eight years old I could remember
having a dream about being 20-something
and in that dream I remember playing the
piano a white piano hearing a melody and
the melody at eight years old in my
dream where I was 20 when dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah dah here 20 years
later 25 years later I grew up I become
famous and I'm sitting at a house where
I bought my first piano which was a
white piano and I began to play a song I
began to start writing on a song and
that same melody when I was 8 came to me
and I couldn't figure out where I heard
this melody from at first I thought I
was like stealing this melody but I come
to realize that as the lyrics came to me
I believe I can fly I believe I can
touch the sky I think about it every
night and day spread my wings and fly
away tear comes down my eye because I
said why I wrote this song when I was a
coming up in the hood I saw so many
things though so many things brought me
all of my dreams and now Here I am Here
I am today
Here I am Here I am today I want to say
I'm proud of my past
um but more than I am proud I'm more
thankful because people ask me all the
time
if you can go back in the past what
would you change I say I wouldn't change
a thing they say what all you've been
through you wouldn't change nothing I
said no they say why I say why should I
look at me I'm strong I'm wise I'm
appreciative I don't take nothing for
granted my pass shaped and molded me
into Who I am today
I think struggle is the best thing if
you know how to deal with it if you know
how to overcome if you know how to deal
with your problems cuz if you know how
to deal with your problems and depending
on how you deal with your problems that
will become the measure that will become
the measure the measure of your worth
but you have to know how to deal with
you anything that happened to me in my
past anything I've been through in my
past I look back behind me and I say
this is where God brought me from
best gift in life it's breathing in and
out so I'm very thankful if I had
nothing if I never saw one record I was
always taught how to be thankful for the
gift of breathing in and out because
long as you can breathe in and out you
can make oh you can make it you can make
it you can make you can make it up you
can make it as long as you breathing
long as you alive you can make it up and
I always used to sing in the shower
because I was too shy to sing anywhere
else
so I was singing the shower I thought I
started good but you know my sister
would always be on the door tell me to
stop calling halls get out of the
bathroom because she had to get in there
I looked at that like she was jealous
and you know just wanted to get in the
bathroom on the need to get out so she
can be in there 20 times as long as I'm
as I was in there so I thought it'd
sound pretty good the shower gave me an
echo a reverb a reverb that allowed me
to hear myself so beautifully so clearly
that it gave me the confidence to walk
out of the shower eventually and sing
throughout the house of course the house
did not have the same reverb outside did
not have the same reverb but when I
dropped out of high school and became a
street performer I was trying to find
that reverb that could echo my voice
that could echo my life so the world
could hear the gift that I had in me
and people asked me to this day what do
you think about your success how does it
feel to perform in front of a hundred
thousand people holding up candles where
it looks like a sea of fire I said all
that's good and all and I appreciate
that and I'm very thankful being able to
touch so many people with my music with
my songs but I tell you
somehow I got that same feeling when I
was a street performer down in the
subways of Chicago yeah that's right
I was a street performer I was a street
performer I was a street performer I was
a street performer now and I will always
be first a street performer because that
allowed me to develop my craft develop
my gift and besides it's a great act go
down there as well
it was a great I go down there except
for the Ale coming back but when the L
will come by I was trying to challenge
that L and sing loud in the Ellen Elroy
I would try to sing louder and louder
and louder louder
lb we're going by I would get frustrated
because I'm gonna get my money if these
people don't hear me singing man I want
to tell people what made y'all put an L
here I'm trying to sing but then I come
to realize that hey sometimes you have
to rise of the noise find a way to rise
above the noise Rob and I tried to rise
above the L still wouldn't work so I
became real slick I would be singing
like this someday the world would know
my name I would be singing like this
someday the world would know my name and
here comes the L and here come the air
and here comes the air and I'll shut up
into the air stop and when the air stop
it became quite a kid and I would say I
know someday the world and all robbers
Robert's name and the people with clap
oh I said that is gotta wait to the L
stop that allowed me to develop my
patience once I developed my patience I
come to find that I had learned how to
sing with strength because before I
learned how to develop my patience I
actually learned how to sing loud trying
to sing over the air which gave me
strength in my voice which gave me the
ability to be
to wring out like a bell when I sing it
also allowed me to connect with people
because I would be singing my songs that
I wrote but I didn't feel there was a
connection the only time I felt the
connection is when I started noticing
people were coming down from work to
catch the L and he had McDonald bags in
their hands and I was like um
McDonough's if I ride a McDonald's song
while these people are holding McDonald
bags in their hands I'm gonna connect
cuz they're gonna laugh and they're
gonna say I can't believe these guys
down here with a piano on a chitlin
bucket singing to McDonald song and I
just came from McDonald's they're gonna
feel like I'm talking directly to them
and that's going to make the connection
so that's what I did I went home I said
mama I got a write off
McDonald song she said well you love
McDonald's you ought to be able to write
at McDonald song that's your favorite
restaurant I said that's what I'm gonna
do so I went in the room and I started
messing with my little keyboard Casio
that is and I said through McDonald's is
the place for you when your day is
through you can go to McDonald's and get
yourself a big pack a Big Mac order of
fries I see coke with apple pie no one
does it like McDonald's do
McDonald's and you and the people with
clap and they were going in pockets oh I
gotta pay this guy this guy's too good
oh man I got the dollars in my hair and
he singing McKnight all along he got to
get paid so people started pulling out
50s I went from making maybe ten dollars
a day from being there from 9:00 to 5:00
to making four to five hundred dollars a
day because I made the connection now
that I know how to make the connection
took it to the next level
hitchhiked all the way to LA even on a
motorcycle yeah man like some guy's
motorcycle 18 with a truck broken down
van got me to LA where I lived on Venice
Beach for like six months I'm talking
about the sand park
yeah I lived on the sand part in his
Beach there was a bleacher and there was
a basketball court and I would sleep
under the beach bleacher and I would
wake up and I would play basketball with
the guys that play basketball oh and I
would be killing them they'd be like
where did this guy come from
he's here every morning playing
basketball with us and it was
interesting because I would play
basketball and then I would go in our
street perform with this goddess skates
with the good time on Venice Beach
yeah and it was amazing times because
those were the times I was paying my two
that's right I was paying my dues that's
right I was paying my dues my tools and
sometimes you have to do that you have
to pay your dues you cannot just wake up
and be successful there's no real
success without testimony the depth of
your testimony determines the height of
your success it's not where you are
today is not how successful you are
today it's what did you do
where did you go what did you go through
where have you been to to get to this
point that's the engine I learned a long
time ago after performing on Venice
Beach I'd be a street performer in
Chicago I went to every talent show you
know trying to win but I lose all the
time especially in LA because at this
time LA was a you know a place of image
you had to look upon not just sound good
and all I had was basketball gear and I
would do really good in the talent shows
but my image I look like a Hooper
because I was at the time so I lose but
don't don't feel for me because see
losing is only temporary you know losing
I looked at as a rehearsal we all lose
in rehearsal all the time over and over
and over and over again until we get it
right and that's the point of rehearsal
you rehearse and rehearse and rehearse
and rehearse you mess up you mess up you
mess up
until you get it right but la street
performing the doors being closed the
nose and all of those things that was my
meal ticket
somehow and I decided then I didn't want
to be stars in the sky because though
they amazed us as kids you know but they
set their did you set their names barn
but what amazed me and what I've always
wanted to study and always wanted to
become and I decided in my mind I told
my mom I said mama I'm gonna be a
shooting star
she said what you mean say I don't
really know what I mean but I know one
thing I love the shooting star why would
you love the shooters now you don't get
to see it much I said I know it comes it
goes you're lucky if you even see one I
said I know and it's not like the other
stars I said I know but that's the point
if I'm gonna be a star I want to be a
shooting star I don't want to be seen
all the time
that's not what I'm about I'm not about
just sitting around in the sky I want to
soar through the sky in and out of space
people would tell me well you could do
that you know sky's the limit I said no
it's not I would always have my
different sayings I would say space is
the limit but if you can make it to
space you can travel anywhere and my
brain and my mind I mean you know it it
just always wanted to go places no man
is gone so to speak you know I always
wanted to be a scientist of music not
just music I wanted to experiment with
my music I wanted to do arm arm beam but
I also wanted to do the world's greatest
but at the time I was told no you stay
in this Lane R&B artist you're going to
do the artist thing you you're not an
arm be king and this
the other I was never interested in
being harm became people put that label
on me and I appreciate anybody for
saying that I'm the best at something
but I never wanted to be the best at one
thing never wanted to be the best at arm
being I just wanted to be great at music
so I decided to do I believe I can fly I
decided to go on and do the world's
greatest I decided to do country songs
pop songs you know you were not alone
for Michael Jackson because I never
wanted to be trapped in a category and
somebody said oh that's the army king I
wanted to be known for just music that's
mr. music yes he has no lane the highway
the streets is he is if he wanted it to
be but I came up in Chicago and the
minute I was born is the minute my
father left my mother yes the minute I
was born is the minute my father left my
mother and I use acts my mother where is
well it's my father and every time she
shunned a question she pushed me away
she said never ask me that again son
never asked me that again but it was
hard because I would always see you know
my brother's you know a father would
come by every now and then and you don't
take them out behind them things and
Christmas Thanksgiving Easter you know
Halloween and I wasn't jealous of my
brothers but I would always you know
become curious and frustrated because
you know wanting a father not having to
file the first of all it's automatically
something missing in your life you know
there's no doubt about that is you know
I always felt half I always felt
a hole in the situation though my mother
was a mother father brother sister best
friend and everything to me she never
was really a father my sister father
would come to every now and then but I
never understood why my father was not
with my mother that was just a something
as a child I didn't understand it would
hurt so damn bad it would hurt so damn
bad and me being 8 years old I would be
so damn sad as I got old as I got a hold
I became closer to my mom me and my mom
would go to McDonald's before she go to
work before I go to school and she would
get us a Danish it's all we could afford
as a Danish in a cup of coffee but and
we would split the Danish and cup of
coffee she would his cheap lipstick and
she would I put three creams and six
sugars in the coffee and she was stirred
up she would open the Danish split it
with the little plastic white knife
she had this cheap lipstick and she
would taste the coffee to make sure it
was sweet enough and she leaves the ring
of lipstick on the coffee which she
tastes the coffee and I remember when
she would give me mine when I was sick
from the cup I would turn it around and
I would drink from her lipstick part
because in the Sun by the way I had a
serious serious crush on my mom because
she could sing about
and I just looked up and down to her I
looked around I look everything about my
mother
you know I love them and I even asked
her to marry me one day I was like nine
she said no but you know what I
understood I understood I took it well
and so when my mom passed I was coming
from my first concert from overseas
which I wanted her to go with me because
that was the only way I was gonna get on
the plane huh
so when I got back from overseas and my
mom passed the day I got back three
weeks later I went away she is heavyset
she was my mom I come back she was very
very very very very very very very very
very very very skinny I had no idea she
had cancer
I had no idea she was even sick I went
straight to Rosalyn hospital in 111 in
Chicago and my sister and brother I
remember them to this day
she's mom's very sick you might not want
to go in there right of course you think
it cold you're thinking the ammonia you
thinking she's gonna be okay so I go in
the room peek my head in see the pastor
with my mother see the doctors first
thing my mom said is she screamed get
out of our bird I don't want you to see
me like this
get out Robert I don't want you to see
me like the
is all I can say is I'm sorry mom I'm so
sorry I didn't know what else to say
didn't even look like my mother but I
knew it's my mother I walked up to her
bed that is the doctor who passed
excuses if my brother's name they excuse
us it was me and my mom she said please
leave please I said mama please don't
make me leave some I gotta tell you
I said first of all I love you and I
thank you for everything you have done
everything everything you've done for me
mom and I'm sorry for every time I've
been bad or did something I wasn't
supposed to do and I promise you she
died right there only I promise you
called the doctor they came in they
pronounced her dead I was still holding
her hand but I finished my sentence see
I promised your mama no matter what by
any means necessary I will be the one of
the best singers songwriters this world
has ever seen
I made my mom that promise and I'm still
on a journey today to fulfill that
promise in which I will perform and sing
and write like one of the best who has
ever done it
I told it to my mom only to my gift
more than anything now hold it to my
fans just to be one of the best not the
best one of the best who has ever done
it's gonna be a little turbulence but my
teacher mentor pasta and I like to call
her my mrs. Miyagi my music teacher Lena
McMann
she said do not write songs write life
sex is life so don't judge me don't be
mad at me if I make a gospel album
that's life don't go getting hating and
spreading rumors on me because I made a
club banger that says you may be used to
me spending and all that sleep wining
and dining learn [ __ ] you tonight now
don't judge me
because I don't judge nobody when I go
and see a good movie and somebody get
the head blown off I just enjoy the
movie and I appreciate the movie I
appreciate the writing I appreciate how
they told the story I appreciate I don't
get into oh man they got all these guns
and they shooting kids and they shooting
these people so don't get mad at me if I
write a song say you remind me of my
Jeep
it's just metaphors it's just
entertainment
it's the gift no different than Bruce
Lee
it's a gift
Bruce Lee was Ali Ali was Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan was Superman Superman
with spider-man and spider-man was
Batman Batman was Martin Luther King I
Luther King was Moses there's certain
people certain images that come to
entertain us to take us through history
and all food genres and decades and
years and years of struggling but
inspiring us to be successful at the
same time that's all I want to be don't
hit me
I'm an artist people and artists are
going to go to depths chosen artists I
decided not to climb the mountain first
I decided to learn how to hold my
balance that's the struggle once I
struggle and learn how to hold my
balance then I can start my client
because why the mountain is a peak at
the time it's very windy you can get
blown off just like that that's why I
decided to hold my balance learn the
hold my balance first because I don't
want to stop my client
I'm and get a fare in the easiest thing
blow me off I want to be able to hold my
balance and hold my balance strong I
want to be able to stand at the top of
that mountain say I'm not coming down
until I feel like it I've earned that
right
because I worked my ass off trying to
hold my balance yes right I'm proud of
me I don't have pride I'm just proud of
me and I suggest no I urge you to do the
same to think the same feel the same be
the same learn how to hold your balance
before you start climbing that mountain
because that's how one hit wonders
happen everybody so anxious to climb the
mountain and knock all the people down
trying to get there and when they get to
the top they start developing a pride
and an ego and out of nowhere whatever
happened to us what's that guy name he
was out here that one song he didn't
learn how to hold his balance before he
started his climb that's why I'm still
here that's why I'm still in the game
because to me it is not a game people
say this people say that they talk about
me behind my back they talk about me in
front of my face they talk about me at
the side I can hear the whispers I can
see the gestures I can feel the spirit
of negativity all around me people steal
my watches they steal my my my cars they
steal my gold and steal everything from
me you take my money
mmm
but I wouldn't change a thing
cuz I'm not in it for money
not anything watches I'm not in it for
jewelry I'm not in it for women
I'm not even for cars and clothes and
houses and this is just something I was
born to do and I will be doing it until
Jesus come back I love music I'm
pregnant by it
I'm having a plaits yeah you're gonna
love my babies I'm gonna raise I'm gonna
come over boom they're gonna poop all
those things out this morning to get
them ride my bike 14 years old my mom
said you can go two blocks and come back
I said okay mama two blocks and back
okay mama two blocks and back I promise
two brats and back then I get on my
little huffy do like this cuz I used to
do this because I just didn't want to
think it was a motorcycle and I say boom
boom boom boom boom
and I started paddling my bike thought I
was the coolest guy in the world heard a
gunshot I look to my right of them to my
laughing them high me I know what
happened and out of nowhere I started
feeling woozy got really dizzy
I started feeling myself then I felt and
I did this my hand was full of blood and
I loved my arm was swollen up so big
like a kneecap was on my arm right here
and I failed I hit the ground off my
bike and I remember opening my eyes just
a little bit I saw these guys running
towards me and I said to myself
but actually it was the guys that shot
me they were taking my bike laying there
I can hear people screaming I could hear
people coming next thing you know I
remember waking up in the hospital and I
remember the doctor telling my mother
did they couldn't move the bullet out of
my arm it's gonna grow a tissue around
it because it's too close to a nerve if
they touch that nerve it could paralyze
my whole arm or the right side of my
body
oh don't y'all touch me I have a career
you know
14:13 but I'm gonna be somebody and I
can't do that being paralyzed I said
mama please don't let him cut me mother
she said don't worry about it baby they
not gonna touch you it's gonna be all
right you're gonna be all right at the
time I really love basketball I thought
I'd never shoot the ball again but I
developed a shot it's funny because the
bullet was in my arm and every time I
shoot a ball or lift my arm I feel that
bullet that bullet I decided was going
to be the constant reminder of the
terrible luck I had coming up as a kid
or it was gonna be a wonderful reminder
how lucky and how blessed I am to be
here today and of course I chose the
second one are you kidding me look at me
look what I've been through look look
how many people I believe I can fly has
been able to touch from here to Africa
and everywhere around the world
all kids graduating to it people feeling
like they can walk out of the hospital
and they feel better they don't even
have to know who wrote the song is
people they love the song and don't even
identify me with the song I'm good with
that because that song was not about me
that song was a seed planet in the earth
for people to grow and blossom and going
and live their dreams like I've been
blessed and able to do mine coming up in
the hood my mother and my stepfather
fought like cats and dogs I hated it
but somehow the love she had for him I I
chose to love him to wear my brother's
name Oh another story my sister they
hated him I found a way to love him
because my mom loved coming up in the
hood
I don't even know how I got here
I don't I don't even know I don't know
what these cameras are about I don't I
don't know magazines and photo shoots
and videos and wart shows and Grammys
and it's all still so surreal to me
because my past is so strongly embedded
in my head and it's I don't know how I
look past all of that and made it to
where I am today but I'm thankful that I
did I'm thankful because I want somebody
else out there to say wow he did it I
can do it all you have to do just
believe all you have to do is have faith
all you have to do is see what it is you
want and become very stubborn and become
very determined nobody but nobody's
going to tell you that success ain't
mine that basketball scholarship that
that that trophy that championship game
that ring that football touchdown that
isn't mine and now that I got the ball
right life pass me the ball I got it I
caught it
I'm running if I stop I'm gonna get
tackled by a lot of people tri-state
I stay running from now on I'm gonna be
on the bright side of things no more I
can't do it
it's my life I'm gonna live here and
maybe maybe I'll succeed what a
wonderful thing to get about this hood
would be and maybe maybe times will
change someday the world they would know
Roberts name